What can termites teach us about
designing green buildings?
As it turns out, a lot.
In Namibia, SEAS researchers led by Professor
L. Mahadevan are studying
how African termites use solar energy to heat,
cool and ventilate their massive colonies.
Termite mounds have long fascinated scientists.
These feats of natural engineering built
from saliva and mud can reach up to 20
feet high.
While they might look like sky scrappers
termites actually live deep underground.
The mounds are complex climate control systems,
regulating temperature and CO2 for the colony
underneath.
In a recent paper, professor Mahadevan and
his team found that mounds in India and Africa
harness periodic solar heating to drive
ventilation inside them in very different
environments, functioning as an external lung.
Using a specially designed sensor, the researchers
found that solar heating creates temperature
gradients that drive wind currents inside
the mound.
As the sun moves across the sky, the wind
circulation inside the mound reverses,
moving gases around in the mound
and allowing for carbon dioxide and oxygen
to be exchanged efficiently across the walls
of the mound.
The researchers hope this will inspire
human
architects to design better heating, cooling
and ventilation systems, making our buildings
greener and more efficient.